[Music]
mark is in miami hey mark welcome to the
show
hi good afternoon mr ramsey thanks for
taking my call sure what's up
um so i have a question regarding uh my
and my wife's student loan situation the
best way to
to approach it we do have a large amount
of student loan debt
it's uh just around four hundred
thousand dollars combined good lord
who's the doctor
well i'm i'm an attorney um and i've
been out of school for about six years
my wife i just graduated from nurse
anesthesia
school this december and so
i have approximately 250 000 and she has
about 150 000 please tell me both of you
have wonderful incomes as a result of
this
uh i think we do we have a combined
income of just under three hundred
thousand two hundred and ninety five
good okay all right we're on our way and
hers is probably going up from there
maybe it may be faster than yours
depending on what kind of law you're
practicing
definitely faster than mine yeah
wow and so oh very good well no i was
gonna say i mean that's that's part of
the the the ray of hope and the story
with 400 000 in debt though is that your
income it's a big shovel you guys have a
big hole but you got a big shovel
and so
being able to attack
the debt with this you guys will make
good progress um
in a much faster obviously period of
time then you know the average household
income in america is 65 000 right
yeah no we're definitely in a good spot
and i guess i know but my point is what
if you lived on that
that that is a good point yeah and that
would be like 200 000
a year towards your student loans and
you'll be done in two years
yeah
so that's a very good point a very good
way to look at it
um that yao didn't sound real convincing
it is but you signed up for this trip
brother
yeah no you're what's the other factor
mark i i interrupted you you were about
to talk and i interrupted earlier so is
there another factor um
yeah it was just um how to how you all
would uh recommend
approaching it because we have two sets
of of loans and and as you all are aware
with these loans are individual per
semester or per section of the school so
they all have different principal
amounts and different interest rates and
is there a way that you would recommend
approaching that as opposed to i would
just listen to the smallest smallest
loan to largest loan
but more than anything what you guys
need to do is you need to really say to
yourself
do we want to screw around with this
mess
for 10 years
or do we want to go scorched earth
where our lawyer and doctor friends
think we've lost our minds
and be done with this fast
i will tell you that your probability of
getting out of debt and becoming
extremely prosperous
increases by every year you cut off this
get out of debt plan
understood so i would be i would be if
if i woke up in your shoes knowing what
i know
i'd be band-aid off rip it off guy i'd
be
i i'm we're doing nothing we're not
going on vacation we're broke
yeah we're a lawyer and a doc nurse
anesthesiologist but but we're broke we
are four hundred
thousand dollars in debt
we are broke
and this is the way i start talking to
myself and go no we're not buying a car
we're broke
no we're not going on vacation we're
broke
no we're not going out to eat we're
broke we're going to live on 65 000. i
don't really care what your stupid
friends think
i'm getting out of debt because dude if
you get rid of this you know what you
got you got a 300 000 going on a 400 000
income with no debt you're gonna be so
stinking wealthy you're gonna be able to
do anything you wanna do the rest of
your life
that's how i would approve that that's
how i'd approach no no i i appreciate it
yeah looking at the
the long game looking at the end yeah
the end game and
the problem is in your world it is so
in
lawyer world doctor world nurse world it
is so normal
to walk around for a decade with this
backache
when you make more money than 98 of
people out there walking around
and they just they they i got to tell
you man
i i meet broke attorneys all the time
and they just
because they've normalized it
that this is okay
and when other people in other
industries look at it and they just
freak out going oh my god he's got you
know but in your world it's just
normalized and you if you're not careful
man because you're running around with a
bunch of people who on the financial
side of things are
stupid
they're stupid
uh and and they're keeping these loans
around and they it's just a way of life
is just part of it and they walk around
with this backache man you ought to get
you ought to get fired up and i want you
to be a weird lawyer
and it would be it would be interesting
mark the exercise of
getting just a investment calculator out
and saying what if we invested our
student loan payments so say we had so
just say you did this plan right you
went two years scorched earth paid it
all off and then you took what is your
student loan payment every month and put
it in an investment calculator and just
play it out it's like tens of millions
of people play it out and just see okay
what what could it be this is what it's
costing you and for for a short-term
sacrifice for what you guys could do i
mean it's it's amazing and i think what
would be hard too is with this income
the pain probably isn't really there
it's not like
so so you have to almost create this
urgency even though you're not feeling
it like i even hear it in your voice
mark there's not an urgency there's not
an urgentness i'm more scared for you
than you are
so you so
fine find the why what is it what is it
about this debt
that's gonna piss you off and say man if
we had just paid it off earlier what
would we have done right like like run
all the scenarios look at all of it
because you could you guys could have a
lot of money which is awesome because
you can do a lot of fun stuff
help a lot of people
your life could really be different if
you just said hey what if we got rid of
this debt this massive the difference in
what i'm talking about and what you're
thinking about is 10 million dollars
that's the difference
you need to get that in your dadgum head
man
because you're gonna you're gonna screw
around with this thing and you're gonna
normalize it and you're gonna keep your
stupid law your lifestyle while you're
broke
and you're gonna take ten years to do
this versus two years to do this and the
difference is ten million dollars
that's what's that's what's gonna cost
you and what the money should have done
that's fabulous income should have
become
what you could have become but you've
got to pay a price to get there and
here's the interesting thing
you do have you and your wife have the
unusual ability to
delay pleasure for a greater gain we
know this because you went to law school
that's while everybody else was finished
their undergrad went to work but you
delayed pleasure for a greater gain she
went to anesthesia school you delayed
pleasure for a greater gain and that's
all i'm trying to get you to do is apply
that that level of maturity to the math
on this money situation
and if you do that
dude but if you get dr itis
where you come out and have to look like
you're a dead young rich lawyer when
you're broke and miami may not help
either you're not living in des moines
there's a there's a flashiness to miami
which is fun but the culture too you're
going to push back you're going to get a
lot of stay out of miami
yeah this is the ramsey show